hey what's up thanks for turning in
another episode of let to be talked
bitchin this is like a trifecta today
it's a bitchin and it's a handmade
episode because we're going to have a
great guest on in a little bit here that
does some unbelievable art before we get
into that Spicer is here today we're all
things comedy studio and he just came in
with the iPhone se which at first I was
clowning it when it came out I was like
wow what a dumb release but then as I
started reading about it I was like
actually this is a good release if
you're into which I think a lot of
people are starting to go back to phones
that are kind of small or not small but
one handed one handed phones yeah so the
SC if you don't know which I didn't know
so I'm just [ __ ] on on Twitter it's
basically a 6s in a 5s body yeah so you
get all the great fast new [ __ ] like the
processor and and all that you don't get
the great turnaround camera but still
other than that you get the credible
battery the same rear cam the old front
cam yeah and a no force touch screen but
with my use before it's like I didn't
it's cool it's a cool novelty I don't
ever talk about for stuff eventually I
might want it but for me getting having
a phone that's the size i like that fits
in my pocket well yep like if you're
sitting or standing or riding a bike
like i love i love the 6s plus like i
think it's a beautiful like if you're on
the road all the time yeah you can just
have that but i need something that like
i can sit comfortably with i can so for
me it was a no-brainer this isn't for
everybody no it's weird too because it's
like challenging your ideal of what like
new tech is yeah cuz i still have that
same one here and it looks the same yeah
it's like no one sees this on the table
and is like oh dude
deneve but it's like this is as fast as
anything of course the seven is gonna
come out in September and before care
better but like I've broken away from
that yearly cycle or whatever and so for
me I still had an original five like not
even a 5s as like my daily work horse
and it was i loved it i would have
stayed with it forever is getting a
little slow and laggy and in the battery
just fell off a cliff but it was a
fourier yeah four year old phone got
your money's worth so we're great like i
would plug it in and it wouldn't even
charge like if i was listening to like
Apple music while it was plugged in it's
like I could see the battery like racing
it's like trying to charge being
depleted trying to check him out apple
gave me a hundred bucks four or five and
in this hundred bucks hundred bucks
that's good so great so I could have
done better on craigslist but I will
know in that [ __ ] battery right and I
was just like here you go they gave me
100 this is the 64 gig one so they don't
make 128 in them bummer the bummer so
they called me a couple days ago
t-mobile out of nowhere and they were
like which I'm not promoting t-mobile
their garbage there are arbiter I'll go
all of you are garbage they're all
garbage but the CB radio works better
than all these [ __ ] garbage things
you can pick up grandpa's CB and talk to
a guy in Germany for free right now and
I just did a bid on it that's we're all
going back to ham radios from now on
like hold on I gotta get outside but
they call me and they go yay Dean your
contract I don't have a contractor error
but they're like your phone's paid off
and everything and we'll give you 300
bucks have you come in and get a new
phone are you okay cool so how much for
a 6s plus and get it 128 yeah she was
all I call you back and so she goes bang
she as well you'll have to put down to
99 and then you can add the phone like a
way to me you're giving me 300 right why
do I have to put any money down you know
all sudden it's a [ __ ] shake and fake
yeah they want to get me in the store
and then roll the 300 is like a rebate
you get later on
and all this [ __ ] was like see you
later but I am thinking about kidney se
because i read the battery life is
incredible and I've been on this phone
forever and I know I really want the 6s
plus cuz it's big but I know I'm going
to be like this [ __ ] thing all the
time it is a beautiful phone but for me
we have a couple I have a couple of
friends that have it and they either
carry a bag with them everywhere which
is fine yeah or they have it in their
back pocket that's just not doable for
me I just like though I know it was like
my comfort and I'm sitting or my comfort
of like having this eight-hundred-dollar
device sticking out out of my back
pocket I don't want that yeah I don't
want that and if I'm carrying a bag with
me I like Apple products they've been
good to me but I have an ipad mini so if
I'm gonna have my bag with me my mini
lives in the bag I'm going on the road
like a short trip I have a nice keyboard
case for my mini that's my yeah no
matter town I can do pretty much every
work i need to do on this and then this
is you know i could tattoo this on me
right this is always on me I gotta run
to spending the same amount of money on
a phone as an apple air computer it is
crazy it's [ __ ] stupid is crazy that
is like somehow America has just been
like yeah I'm cool with that I bought an
apple air it's the same price as the
Apple 6s plus 128 gig yeah that sounds
about right what the [ __ ] what the
phones if conditions you and there's no
good like I always buy my phones out
right yeah cuz I've broken myself from
like I think if you're on that one year
upgrade cycle and you always need the
thing I imagine either apple or AT&T or
one of them has like a plan that saves
you some money yeah but I've broken all
those got like a jump plan yeah whatever
it is I've broken myself from that
height need to have the thing and so I
by the phone I'm going to use it for it
to life but otherwise that it's like the
pricing of these things is so convoluted
like okay come in it's 299 down and
they're going to add four dollars to
your statement every month that you're
paying plus another then you'll get a
different statement that's an install
and you're just like what the [ __ ]
that's all job and so like you don't
realize that you just spent eight
hundred dollars on a thing like who
who gives like their macbook air to
their two-year-old yeah like here you go
play with that you'd be like you're
gonna [ __ ] break it I see parents all
the time they're like here you go Timmy
and it's like a 6s plus and I'm like you
just give that kid a thousand dollars
well are you doing yeah it's brill I
can't like the idea of the SC I really
want to know how long your battery lasts
yeah I haven't done a crash test on it
but just coming from you know my last
phone where it was tanked to this I'm
like all day I don't plug it in i'm
streaming music it's been it's been
great I'm very happy so far i'm about to
look at and [ __ ] you know because it's
so funny because i love the big one
because i can't see but now i got my
glasses glasses yeah they're updated i
can see great it's so funny now when I
got the phone on the side it's over here
yes yeah and I'm just but my main thing
still is [ __ ] the touchscreen I just
suck at it and I wish the voice texting
was way better yeah it's just so shitty
yeah you know yeah um google voice and
the best voice recognition things that
i've used on a daily basis or google
whatever the google one is called and
then amazon's alexa or like amazon we
have like one of those take a portable
speaker and just like artificial
intelligence it's incredible like I can
be blasting you know like ac/dc and it's
playing out of that speaker and I can
still go sorry if anyone has one right
now I would go like Alexa what's the
weather and it hears me over it's
awesome Wow hey Siri [ __ ] nothing
that wouldn't work like that don't you
gotta press the button not anymore no no
hey Siri Wow hey Siri [ __ ] that one at
work best run I'd blush if I could it's
like ver it's like I know Magnus mine
dear yours has to be plugged in but
newer ones don't have to be yeah yeah
mines hittin myth I'm surprised that
work to be honest yeah yeah all right
we're gonna have guests today calling in
and this is a great thing I absolutely
love Instagram I cannot grasp and and
and I'm not some old man I am a wizard
at
at social media I like it yeah I'm
addicted to it unfortunately it's like
cocaine I'm a [ __ ] idiot on it all
day and I like it though and really they
really it's fun especially Instagram I
don't like I said I don't good snapchat
yeah I just sit it's a clunky format
yeah I don't see a feed which I don't
like I like feed yeah you know where I
can see what people are doing and it's
to swipe left right up down it's all I
think it's just a bad format I can't
believe it to me it's like Facebook I've
said it over and over can't believe it's
taken off well we we're getting into
snapchat too late right like snapchat
started because it was a way for kids to
send each other yeah a sexy pics yeah
yeah we're talking about that yeah yeah
yeah so but we haven't lived so now it's
like iterated on for four years or
whatever and now we're coming into this
thing as like men being like what the I
don't [ __ ] but kids have grown up
with it like of course it's buddy-buddy
it but it really I don't know anyway we
got the call in right now and he's he's
our guest today let's let's get him on
the phone here right now hey man are you
there it's Dean hey be meeting you up in
here thank you for having me Jeff park
right that's it that's a senior last
night now we are we are streaming live
you can swear whatever don't worry about
it but I want people to know your insta
your Instagram is j dot PA RK e right
yeah the reason I want people to know
why we're talking so they can see what
the hell we're talking about my co-host
is here Christian Spicer hey what's up
man think your stuff is incredible
incredible Thank You Christian yeah
thank you appreciate her now my I do a
series called handmade I always have
people on that make incredible stuff it
by hand in America mostly you know I've
had guys on that do other jackets denim
and everything and a great thing of
Instagram I was just getting into it
before you called is people turn me on
to great stuff cars motorcycles clothing
concert photos but a guy a week ago
hits me and says hey Dean I bet you like
this because i love the grateful dead
and i love Rolexes he sends you this
sends me a photo of a milgauss you did
and it is unfuckingbelieveable this
watch and it actually fell out of the
chair for a few minutes looking at it
and I'll show I'll show unchristian
Spicer here your work now that thing
immediately I've known a lot of guys at
hand in grave and stuff like shotguns I
know a guy that used to do air cleaners
for Jesse James at west coast choppers
okay yeah very cool yeah so um how did
you get into this and how long have you
been doing it and tell us your process
first of all it's all done by hand right
yeah it's all done by hand I do use some
air tool on steel is extremely difficult
to cut I mean when I started out it was
all hand push and jewelry and then you
have guys when you even a skill you
don't have to use the old school hammer
and chisel way which there's a few guys
would still do that but nowadays it's
all air tools which is basically you
have a hand tool that has a fifth
intimate and you know acts as a hammer
well I haven't kind of like a touch
tattoo gun a little bit exactly that's
probably the closest thing that you know
I'm basically what I'm doing is I'm just
tattooing steel in a way no I mean the
processes are very similar with layout
and and you know how at yours basically
do their work there's a lot of
similarities and so I got into this dude
doing jewelry work I have family that's
been in the jewelry business for you
know generations two brothers on jewelry
stores one of them grabbed me and you
know asked if i wanted to do start doing
goldsmithing you know stone setting
repair work so i started doing jewelry
work which you know I kind of Excel that
I tend to be good with my hands were you
in love with were you a draw before you
sore a painter because
this is a chicken [ __ ] yeah I did no I
grew up drawing like everything a little
kid you know going to school excelled in
all my art classes didn't ever pay
attention in class just drew over you
know all over my books so grew up with
an art background um so there's a lot of
art in college didn't really go anywhere
with it I just didn't you know didn't
think that you could make money doing
that I did then I was a musician I mean
I played guitar w this day Wow were you
need any bands I was a lot of GarageBand
come on Louie or where'd you grow up in
Utah yeah southern Utah Wow what's hard
yeah so what's my part of each oh I'm
sorry st. George Oh got ya hop right on
the Arizona border right on the very
southern border about an hour and a half
of it a year at what point I mean like
my grandfather was an impressionist
painter and if he messes up it's like oh
it's uh it's a hundred-dollar canvas or
whatever like at what point someone's
like here's this blank canvas by the way
this blank canvas is a
fifty-thousand-dollar Rolex watch yeah
like how to have fun like how I mean
you're doing it by hand to I just
picture my hands just shaking non-stop
of them like please don't mess up please
don't mess up please don't [ __ ] I do
yeah the one gets on someone's skin yeah
hi dear guys I and I [ __ ] of it as
their ways to fix stuff that we don't
know about while you're doing it um very
cleaning mistakes what you have to do is
you just have to implement it you slip
and make a cut where you weren't
supposed to basically you have to like
implement that into your design or if
it's teeny you can you know go hammer
that area out file it down sand it
smooth so for the most part you can't
really make too many mistakes so if you
know is nerve-racking and it does
required you know you have to be pretty
focused everything's done under a
microscope so any detail detailed work
so do you work now this this particular
grateful
headpiece was 250 hours you said yeah it
leave I didn't keep track of that one
there was a big big project was that
commissioned was a guy a Grateful Dead
fan or are you a Grateful Dead fan how
did that come about so I've been ever
since I got an Instagram I've had people
contact me I don't know if you've seen
me I guitar picks that I've been grave
yeah we're looking at those rage but
yeah I did a bunch of grateful dead ones
you know I don't know probably a few
years back and some people saw really
like them a guy out of New York crisper
with her jewelry I don't know if you
follow him on Instagram your mother and
gray / really you know amazing viewer he
he has a lot of offense that collectors
work and so he commissioned me to do a
Grateful Dead relaxing for him yah was
oh that's for him yeah he has clients
that by them so I did it for him you
know he had you know I don't can't
remember who bought it there's we've
done three of them so far what do they
sell for that's a good question I don't
even know Wow now yeah man sounds like
quietly 30 Wow 30 got so a guy turns in
his Rolex so he already has to buy the
watch and then it's 30 on top of that or
is it 30 all in um I don't know I know
that a mill girl full run your brand-new
around eight yeah I know that but I'm
saying on top of that is it is it
another 25 grand to do the in greater
yeah on top yeah you're putting a leaf
another 20 on top Wow I don't not sure
how much you sold 40 on it right now
when you when you're sitting down do you
work eight hours a day every day or how
do you do it you know what I yeah more
yeah still working a full-time jewelry
job at the time so I work I run a repair
shop full time and I ungrateful time
whoa so thanks for being here
to a bench yeah i work seven days a week
for the most part wow man so now do you
take the rolex apart yourself since
you're a jeweler I take it apart myself
yeah luckily I you know taking her ology
classes I work with watches for the last
10 years no not that big of a deal take
part that's incredible spicer if you
were getting a watching grave do you
could have anything engraved on it would
you do a band or like because he did one
with you didn't want with skateboard
theme right like bones brigade or
whatever the buffered yeah unbelievable
i freakin love there's a kid yeah i
actually gave that to stacy peralta it
was a knife oh that's def safety topic
how for altai I i gave that to him he's
a he's a really cool guy yeah I think
that was another watch what I want to do
I want to do a food fighters launch wow
really are you Foo Fighters fan just a
little bit haha yeah now huge Foo
Fighter Spanish I've done some some mega
targets were Foo Fighters I have a
portrait of dave grohl on one of them
wow wow man spice who would you get I
think my I would want to ban that kind
of blends where I'm from so it'd be like
California picturesque beaches mountains
and then Texas kind of prairies big star
yeah a blue bonnet something like that
landscapes yeah dobe landscape I'd be
cool i wouldn't mind having like
Yosemite Half Dome some grizzly bears
the California actual the shape you know
that shape of the state all that would
be great but really I think I would wear
that Grateful Dead one for the [ __ ]
day I died what if there was a boss got
left you know I thought about I thought
about AC DC and stuff but there's
something a little bit trashy about that
Grateful Dead really felt like it worked
with it to me you know its iconic at the
iconic band with iconic iconic I könig
Rafi icona grab the energy you know the
images right right w know the Bears I'm
a Grateful Dead fan I you know I'm a
little younger so but I did see them and
I
five bad Angus right before Jerry died
i'm not the biggest fan but it was their
imagery that really always influenced me
write another steely skull on the Jerry
bears just you know yeah absolutely
laptop that I thought was very cool so
now let's talk a little bit how you your
first one you do is is the Grateful Dead
one the first one you did know so my
first I've been engraving high-end
knives for about eight years right I
took I took my omega seamaster apart
years ago and engraved it mom just you
know I pretty much it's cut everything
that's metal I have a nice i just might
as well embellish it right deep you do
any nose candy while you're doing it man
it's so like tedious right I'm yeah what
I don't know about no scare me but I'm
addicted to caffeine that's for sure I
could live without my five hour energy
wow so you got the watch and it's just
sit you got a piece and is it in a vise
or something and then you've got like a
move or something that's how you doing
will having it yeah and engravers ball
is justify that spin just has bearings
I'll just spins so you just hold your
cutting tool in your right hand and you
spin the vice with your laughs that's in
just inside line one after another it
seems to me the sky is the limit here
man like i was looking at it I was
thinking these are you you could do
incredible wedding rings guitar picks
for guitar picks for awards or invites
to stuff you know amazing those guitar
picks could be great necklaces you know
you drill a hole in it and and your
stuff is insane now how do you do the
your engraving into it and then you drop
gold in there is that gold leaf or is it
actually poured in there it it's
24-karat most i use wire so basically if
i'm going to put
gold into an area i have to cut that
area completely out relieve it then I
kind of make cuts in the bottom like the
piece of a file and 24 karat gold is so
soft that you just hammer it in oh wow
either you just hammer it in they never
file it off and sand it off it's just
insane this work it's funny because a
guy was showing a guy through your work
and he said oh yeah I got a guy that do
that about three grand and he showed it
to me and I was like you don't see the
difference here huh you know I mean sure
sure it not your Grateful Dead watch but
your other watches that have the designs
on it his were similar kind of designs
and stuff but I can see the the the
detail in your line so much it was in it
was night and day it was hilarious how
people always want to cut corners you
know and and and I'll have listeners on
and they'll be like oh this guy's out of
his mind 30 grand engrave your watch but
eh it's whatever [ __ ] gets you off
you know what I mean like I see it and
I'm like man that's something you wear
for the rest your life and no one has
yeah I mean and I lucked out I studied
under three just phenomenal guys
engraving who was a Jason Marquis fava
who you know just in the jewelry world
he's like infamous he currently works
for Tiffany & Company I studied under a
guy named Elaine levenberg who's a
Belgian gun engraver um study that are
here for two weeks Sam alfano he flies
the most affluent popular and graver in
this space you know guys who really mean
this stuff is just classy you know this
there's a lot of engravers out there
like you said someone can do it cheaper
you know yeah just like getting a tattoo
you can get it back patio yeah if I
wanted to be a really really good one I
wanted to get you two Glocks with
pictures of me carved all over them in
every bullet
I see a [ __ ] and Gregor yeah what do we
put hypothetically I got to go oxen and
actually the bullets would say Dean did
this so I would just go murdering people
and that's like another great yeah put
your thumbprint or you know right all
mostly I get engraved ebuddy engraved
Dean's fingerprints on the gun so they
have to find his prints John it right on
it murder was the case that he gave me
yeah yeah yeah that's [ __ ] comedy let
me ask it do you mostly work in
stainless steel Rolexes or our gold ones
no good in grave what's that about
another gold ones are great oh they're
armed oh yeah go go under the fabulous
you can get more detail and steel yep
but I'll tell you what I mean three
series stainless steel which is what
watches are made out of that they are a
nightmare to cut well Rolexes the telus
steel we're in the world lovely rolex
has the toughest team in the world now
they're saying so that's got to be a
nightmare right it's a it's a nightmare
and that's another reason why nobody
wants to touch watches is because
they're just too hard to cut well it
with your new tools it doesn't make it a
little easier or still hard with the air
hammer it does no it makes it makes it
easier but you still have to like you're
just sharpening you know just basically
you can only make so many cuts before
you have to sharpen your tool again
that's a very sharp tool to make you fly
in cuts and so this is a lengthy process
it does to cutting the gold I could cut
for a week straight not have to be sharp
it well yet the same of feel the watches
and here's resharpening like every 5-10
minutes wow wow no [ __ ] and hadn't
sharpen it with a pet with the grinding
home just diamond laps basically you're
just putting facets on these steel
points what carbide actually is what i
use now but that's unbelievable
I have a friend who owns one of my
favorite clothing stores in the world
self edge his name is kia and i had
posted a photo of your watch on my
Instagram and and he and I are into way
high-end ship and he was like this is
this is [ __ ] mind boggling it is you
know it was just and a lot of people
were really blown away by this watch man
this watch is it's I think a lot to do
with it is the milgauss is my favorite
Rolex you have the grain the green
crystal popping off of your gold skulls
and stuff the 24 karat gold skulls this
watch is just a [ __ ] piece of art man
yeah it you know I I appreciate you
loving it I mean I I i love it too i do
i really put like my blood sweat and
tears into this stuff yeah i just love I
got into engraving I never thought I'd
make any money at it I did I just you
know had to learn how to do it right you
know and it's now I got paying off
because people are paying me to do cool
stuff no but I really do try to put my
best work into every piece I do can
somebody go to you directly to get
something done absolutely I mean if they
want to contact me via Instagram know
how they can just be a me on instagram
or my email is also on Instagram I might
I might I might have to give you a watch
you do my watch and I'll trade
advertisement for ya logo fate maybe I
can like put your initials on it Oh
welcome to let there be talk episode 4
million two hundred thousand six hundred
ah hey I don't run in the same ad I mean
people pay more for ads than that wats
you know
no I you know I do yeah I mean it could
I don't know much about it I probably
definitely worth it but that I don't
know cash always speaks the loudest oh
yeah I am well you know I get a lot of I
can only grow my business so much
because I'm the only guy who can do this
yeah yeah you know I tried to teach
others and I just they can do it you
know the level was I can so I mean I can
only get so much business like you know
yeah yeah you guys got ya raise those
prices yes it you know there's only one
da Vinci da Vinci could only Michael
angel can only paint so much after that
it's like yeah you gotta gotta pay me
hey is there a line is there a line for
your work right now are you like working
on a watch right now and the next one's
in line what's going on yeah I have I
just finished a piece that I was doing
with my friend Chris sir jewelry right
now I'm doing well I just finished two
watches I have another one that's just
sitting it's just I'm waiting for the
green light to go to pull the trigger
and then you know it's funny as I get a
lot of people who are they're very
interested we just still true email
after email but I think when you're
paying a lot you know it's hard to pull
the trigger sometimes but totally I do a
ton of jewelry I do a ton of knives so
that's my biggest thing its eyes yeah
cuz that's quicker write a couple days
yeah i mean i can pump out you know that
quite a bit quicker right i watch the
fake you know your if you like the
Grateful Dead one I mean you're you know
I'm in it for at least the follow-up six
weeks six weeks straight you worked on
that well that's having a full-time job
and I have a few other engraving as well
oh but you gotta pay the bills I'm
getting married at the end of the month
so I got it you know I want to see that
ring yeah that's got to be impressive
yeah my Instagram oh yeah nice ah yeah
I'm engraving my own ring so i'll have
it on Instagram you know weeks Wow now
you're moving to Scottsdale is that
right I wish I could afford stock sale
mesa mesa well scottsdale see
like a complete area that would buy your
watch is all day long yeah you know i'm
i'm really excited there's a you know
obviously being from a small town in
utah thurs i have no business here yes
all outsourced is it all there whenever
it is now be really it'll be really need
is it is you get in a lot of biz from
your Instagram Todd you know it's been
my Instagram ISM of the best thing ever
for a guy like me I had a web page up
for years and never had any business
that's just exactly what I was just
talking about like Spicer and I we have
a dream of doing a show or we cruise
around America and we just find people
that make great [ __ ] or stuff like that
and and boom there you are without
Instagram I would have never known about
you and even though I'm in too deep
rabbit holes late at night on on the
Internet of iCarly get this [ __ ] you
know it's incredible that you could
Google grateful dead and that watch
didn't come up but BAM Instagram there
it is with a hashtag the power of a
grateful dead hashtag and a Rolex
hashtag and there it was you know yeah
it's been it's been the best thing for
my engraving by far let's ensue thank
thank goodness for instagram instagram
changed my life absolutely and bummer
for me that Instagram worked for it
because i bet i bet you could have got
that done for about 5 K about two years
ago when you're sitting out in you top /
like damn 5k all right I'll do it yeah
yeah now it's gonna cost you yeah okay
I'm going to cut you loose but I really
think thank you for being on the show
and but once again give everybody your
Instagram it's j dot PA RK e right yep
hurt and do you have a website but still
I do not good why is here why honey
that's great and I was a little confused
used when I first found your watch it
seemed to be on three different guys
instagrams are those partners of yours
or what is that yeah so I work with Sir
jewelry he's at fer jewelry since Chris
you sponsored commissioned me to do
these watches for his watch company fin
du temps right that x-fi an EF te MPs
and then what about being there's not a
third person I do people of taken in my
post it yeah got it yeah yeah well I
don't know where it's been I really
here's a guy who I work with for the
most part I really appreciate it and I
love your work man and I hope one person
contacts you from this show and get
something done you know because it's so
your stuff is mind-boggling I mean at
this I have a tattoo on my side done by
nikko hurtado and it reminded me exactly
of your your work when I first saw his
tattoos on Instagram years ago I was
like what the [ __ ] might have been
enough it might have been Twitter but I
was like that's not real you know what I
mean these tattoos your bathing yeah
yeah I've got a bon scott done by him
and your work is equivalent to that when
I saw it I was like what the [ __ ] and I
just started looking around the house
like what could I sell to get that well
I thank you amber one last thing go have
you ever seen Brad Pitt's motorcycle
with a whole motor not the whole motors
engraved yeah there's a bunch of guys
that are doing a motorcycle parts now
yeah yeah there is but very cool that's
like giant engraving to me my stuff is
like a micro yeah engraving the guys who
do those parts man i take me to rest of
my life yeah a guy did my buddy Jeff
Decker's entire gas tank and it's just
roses and it took the guy like
three years I mean not straight but you
know I think after a while you gotta get
the [ __ ] off this tank man you start
yeah yeah all right well you're going to
start seeing more and more engraving
that's for sure it's becoming more and
more popular yeah absolutely thank you
and I I get out to Arizona a lot and I'd
like to meet a man it'd be fantastic
yeah absolutely i'll be in touch all
right thanks for calling in bud thank
you appreciate it see it nice guy yeah
great to write when like someone that
makes awesome stuff seems cool and it's
not just like well you did yeah yeah
like oh it sometimes people that do that
kind of work you are lunatics that's why
they're so good at that they're in their
house with their cat you know have
engraved my entire bomb shelter and it's
safe yeah and you're just like only
can't even talk cuz they've have so many
cigarettes like I never go to the gravy
and everything uh oh I don't sniffing
solder and [ __ ] but was like that stuff
is insane though right mm-hmm I mean
like when you look at it you skill
that's done by [ __ ] hand yeah it's
like I don't wear a watch and I'm
thinking like okay well watch am I
getting high it's like you when you see
really beautiful stuff like that you
start thinking how can I incorporate
some version of that into my life and
not just the consumer consumer aspect of
it but like if you know looking at that
sharing that art looking at that art
every day would make you happier it's
just like having a van Gogh in your
place and nobody else has it incredible
I tell you when you wear a Rolex
everybody in their mom has one pretty
much the Submariner that classic one
when you're out you can go out tonight
just start looking at everybody's wrist
I guarantee you probably count like 20
or 30 you know if you're out in a club
or whatever but if you had this guy and
grave the whole thing you would look
down and then you go what the [ __ ] is
that yeah and that's exactly how I
looked at that mill gasps it was just I
still look at it yeah I look at it like
every couple days i look at this guys
[ __ ] those guitar picks
yeah imagine the viewer just like a rich
guy like Angus Young and you had him do
you 50 pics one for each night on the
tour or / let's just say I just went to
gnr you just had the slash pic and some
lucky [ __ ] in the crowd got that man I
mean that would be like I got the / PK
also in today's day and age what it
would be as / could you know someone gnr
Commission those pics oh really what it
is is coca-cola yeah commissions the
pics yeah / plays with it for one song
whatever it is right welcome to the
jungle yeah afterwards they take it they
put in an awesome velvet crushed velvet
box and then they sell it for charity
yeah for like st. Jude or something like
that for a million bucks and everybody
gets paid and some awesome rich dude has
some dope collectible yeah we got a call
let's grab it man that guy was cool hey
there man hey whats up guys [ __ ] oh man
who's calling where you come from this
is a Bryson has a twitter handle Bryce
Bryce bud from Calgary Alberta all right
oh man Alberta yeah what's up how are
you what's up bud how are you oh [ __ ]
it's cool if I I hear on the phone man
they keep missing you guys's live shows
and [ __ ] but [ __ ] did awesome to be on
here now right on man Spicer's here
today do you have any questions for us
or anything yes for you Dean in a few
spice now what's your guys's thoughts on
the new [ __ ] is had at this can
remember between Spotify and Apple music
which one is better and which one you
saw that is going to help I guess brain
more revenue or help be lean to towards
artists to keep releasing music
digitally or physically or even both
whatever for what streaming services for
me I've decided I went I canceled my
Spotify and I went apple music mostly
because their family plan so like you
know these are first world problems
right like we're all privileges but like
for fifteen bucks a month I have my
own playlists and accounts or whatever
my wife has hers and then we have an
iPad that we use as like a music player
in our girls room so I you know I for
fifteen bucks a month i think it's four
or five simultaneous streams you can
have and spotify to do that was just
more expensive and that's what it came
down to me we're like the catalogues
were pretty much the same but saving
that five bucks or whatever it was a
month and then I it's like it sucks to
keep supporting like I love Spotify they
were kind of the indie company that did
this thing and made it you know kind of
mainstream but apples the thousand pound
gorilla where they can go pay to get
those exclusives so it kind of sucks
just to reward that behavior but I think
if if someone stays in this business
right it's going to be facebook google
apple or something like that but I've
been happy with it so far out the
music's been good to me same here same
here guys like what I first I tried
Spotify and immediately like [ __ ] got
rear like that three day trial like I
[ __ ] this is like blaming [ __ ] i'll just
stick to like doing i do download
whatever and also i'm trying to make an
artist as well too because I've been
trying to you know dab into the whole
turntable is insane oh yeah try to be
like the same thing like Dean Del Rey
did you know like did the guitar I've
been trying to drum scenes here and
there been trying to pick up some bass
launch it and right now it's got back
into more because of Death Grips and
then being shifted my block party and
then of course [ __ ] proggy i think i
told you that on the periscope to Dean
yeah greedy admit you yeah I met I'll be
so [ __ ] cool p got them or even Chuck
D from Public Enemy that was so bad at
Chuck deezen Chuck DS my favorite rapper
besides ice cube ever you know I saw I
saw public enemy on the fear of the
black planet or it was unborn of also
say to that one man I seen him a bunch
after that but that was the one for me
we got another call dude I love you
thanks for calling in no bomb Matt and I
hope you guys come out to Calgary did
I'll be [ __ ] are to come to your show
I'll give a [ __ ] I'll go I don't give a
[ __ ] man seriously thank you so much
dude candles limb thanks man [ __ ] all
right we got another call here at you're
on the air who's calling
no man bet in Tucson how's it going to
go to son Ben what's up buddy yeah what
are you guys doing we're doing a show
what you talking about we're talking
about some dope engraving we're talking
a little bit about streaming music
services and now we want to talk about
whatever you want to talk about what's
up yep well those it does a good topics
actually uh I started doing apple music
a few months back and there's a lot of
things I like about it I love it I love
it we just had a collar on I I think
that it is unbelievable for nine dollars
a month or ten dollars to have every
song ever more or less ever I notice
it's pretty amazing and the thing I like
about it too is all that uh that stuff
on beats one where it's got the human
touch you know what I mean like st.
Vincent has a show and Josh from Queens
has a show and like dr. dre and all
these people so it's like listening to
the radio where you get to hear them
actually talk about the music too and
they're curating all the songs it's real
cool I've never even checked that out
now that's the dr dre show that they
bought right and it's like is it it's
like a radio stations yes so I think you
look at it and the cool thing is you
don't have to just listen to it live
they archive them all yeah but like if
you if you type in Josh Tommy in there
it'll be a couple options you know
they'll be you know Queens and all that
stuff but it'll he has his own show it's
called I can remember the name of it but
it's great because you know you know
he's a funny guy anyway so he always
hams it up and like he even kind of gets
into character and stuff it's really
cool man now are they radio shows or
like podcast yeah yeah no it's well I
mean kind of like a cross between the
two because you know you can tell they
put him they put in time and try to you
know really really make it sound good
but yes it's similar to listen to a you
know a radio show because he'll feel
spin maybe three or four tracks that
he'll get on the mic a little bit yeah
and he'll leave a Gilliam occasionally
have guests you know like musicians that
are friends of his and stuffs really
cool I've haven't even dived into that
party yet and I think that I think it's
going to get better and better and
better you know right now to me it's
just kind of like oh I want to hear
Springsteen the river record and
immediately it's in my [ __ ] hand and
it's not taking up any
memory in my phone and the amount of
space that all my CDs took at my last
house would make your [ __ ] head spin
and these cases I would have to have
people make these shelves and all this
and then I would only listen to about 40
or 50 cds because it's just too many but
now it's just instantly I'm like Siri
play you know mercyful fate and bam
there it is no it's it's pretty amazing
and that's that's one of the things I
think two is like what you're saying how
it doesn't take up any memory cuz I'm a
music nerd like you guys so I mean [ __ ]
most of time on my phone eighty percent
of the [ __ ] on there was just albums
okay yeah that's me it's photos and
music you know and that in my whole
phone back like I was just like I need
128 gigs and it's like I really don't
but in my dumb mind I'm just thinking
like I'll never be fool because I won't
have music in anymore yeah and there
would have to be about a million photos
to fill that up and videos yeah so yeah
I mean I think the only drag about it is
the reason why I'm going to still
continue to always buy music too is
because you know if you want to listen
to some cool [ __ ] when you're camping
sorry no Wi-Fi you get what I mean you
can take it off on I don't want to have
you can copy the [ __ ] we've intended out
my care about enough you can stir it on
offline yeah oh really oh yeah you go
it's so it's a little bit of a nightmare
to find in terms of their UI to turn it
off but yeah if you have the storage
capacity on your phone you can just go
in hit a little button toggle a thing
and download it onto the phone so if
you're on the plane or you're out
camping or whatever you got it ready to
go now you don't need our cloud you can
just put it onto your phone storage yep
you juggle right it will download it to
your phone I didn't even know that I
thought you had to have a cloud account
that's genius that's even [ __ ] better
it's all like paid for whatever that
you're paying for with the service that
you're paying for it's pretty slick and
Spotify does that as well and then
finding like I remember I the time was
like there's nothing on my [ __ ] phone
like why is my mind's my date all like
or wives my memory full and then I was
like oh yeah i just want got back from a
trip and i put all these albums right
side like going in man uncheck them so
you do it before you leave
if you open something up in the phone
where is it at it's in the Apple music
app honestly better than me describing
it to you listeners just google it their
help Oh youtube it yeah it's in the
Apple music app and it's just like I
think you you hit like the three
ellipses in there and open it up and you
can you can download tracks it's uh it's
a slick little thing they did and what I
love it for is you get to make mistakes
whereas before making a mistake on music
was like fifteen twenty bucks or
whatever but now it can be like uh I
don't know if I'm gonna say bands i do
like but it's like oh i used to like the
deftones is their new album any good
yeah it's great but like if I was at a
record shop I'd be like I don't know I
know cuz the sore knee high socks I
haven't listened to deftones in a while
I'll pass and I'm missing out on a dope
record I know the second these records
come out um I immediately listen to him
on Friday yeah you know that Troy van
Lew and he did his his band just put out
a record and bam then it's sweet head
they're called I recommend you guys get
this Troy Van Loon from Queens one of my
favorite guests on the podcast you put
out a record with his wife and bam I got
it you know there it is i'm listening to
it yeah you know which I don't even pre
you can even pretty like I've even you
know like save stuff that hasn't even
been released yet they know maybe and
they'll maybe let you sample one or two
songs even before the record oh yeah I
love that they always say that's great
nope yeah thanks for calling in man hell
yeah love you guys take care see you
about it hey yeah the future is a weird
place it is weird price and like Netflix
and all that stuff is cool too it's just
it's so it's so it's so weird and louie
ck you know how's the great bits about
it but like how we complain when it
doesn't work yeah was because when it
does work it's [ __ ] incredible it's
so addicting yeah that when it doesn't
work you're like what the [ __ ] yeah like
I just scream at t-mobile over and over
and over on on on Twitter yeah and I
tell you everybody if you have problems
with anything tweet it man it's a
powerful message but t-mobile does not
work from once you get outside of LA
you know two on the way to Vegas the
entire 15 sure you can make a call but
you can't surf the net or stream music
or anything it's just shows an e the
entire world until you're like to the
town like Baker or Barstow thing for
about 15 minutes you've got some signal
and y'all [ __ ] all right cool and then
you're back on the road and you can't
listen to any podcast [ __ ] and same with
I five from LA to San Fran and every
time t mobile they say the same [ __ ]
thing and it makes me on they get on the
they get on the Twitter and they go
sorry you're having this problem dms you
shouldn't be having this problem we want
to get to the bottom of it yeah it's cuz
there are no cell towers what day is I
was in you know when I was in Southeast
Asia yeah we were on this this train we
were like on a road out to this remote
town cell towers the whole way Wow it
was like this country has better service
than our infrastructure our country is
huge yeah but our infrastructure is [ __ ]
really as the internet we're paying for
and the speeds we're getting versus
South Korea or like not having internet
be a municipality and it's a again again
though this is me again now I've gone
full circle right now it's just so
amazing everything's great it's so sue
that we ever get mad at things I'm so
[ __ ] mad at that I get it I get it my
point is though it's cell phones 10
years ago we're way better you know
because there was so many people on it
well I also think we didn't expect them
to be able to work all the time when I
first moved to California I was in San
Diego and I knew that there is a place
on my drive to and from work and my
wife's drive to and from work truck it
just didn't work yeah and we just didn't
expect it to work and you knew that that
was it and whatever it was but now you
expect it to work all the time like and
it's hard because because it works most
places you don't think i'm gonna go to
Vegas let me load up on podcast yeah let
me take some albums offline so i have
them ready to go because why the [ __ ]
wouldn't at work between two of the most
like populace
cities are like destinations on the west
coast more than cars every day every day
yeah oh yeah yeah you know the
interesting thing too is I get some
pretty fierce panic attacks when I'm
riding around America like I haven't
done it a couple years but I'll go on a
long motorcycle ride say to Sturgis yeah
and there's some [ __ ] areas man where
I'm like oh I'm done out if i get a flat
I'm [ __ ] done yeah and I mean it you
would be sitting there with no signal
and with a flat tire and maybe a car an
hour and they're not going to stop
because the world of like Charles Manson
they grew up in like I ain't getting
slashed by that biker yeah yeah I mean
so notice an engraved knife yeah this
knife is $50,000 this is [ __ ] just
it's an art piece of delivering to your
[ __ ] neck it's great for dad it's so
[ __ ] crazy though how scary it is
when you're out there like you know and
then you watch the revenant and you're
like the guy walked across America after
being mauled by bears in the snow and he
he slept in a horse is carcass thank you
know what every right so yeah as much as
I think I'm a man biking across America
I'm immediately a [ __ ] [ __ ] the
second I get the flat I'm stuck out here
with these panic attacks I don't have my
ativan where's my Sat phone I knew I
should have got a Sat phone damn now
there is the one guy who is it who's
planning on doing Wi-Fi across America
somehow where the phones are just free
forever there's a couple of different
initiatives are trying to do this I know
Facebook is trying to do one with like
balloons to try to get internet and I
don't know my gut tells me you on musk
is doing something with that but I don't
know I don't know him personally but I
am amazed at the [ __ ] that that man's
created great like it mean it kind of
makes sense to me because it's hard to
slow down inertia but here you know
you've had these huge auto companies
around for forever and there haven't
been able to make significant gains and
electric cars until recently Elon Musk
and whatever it is 10 you
yours is like I got this yep and seems
to be making killer [ __ ] cars I just
released the technology for free yeah to
everyone he said here's the patents and
the the [ __ ] I'm doing if you can make
it better here it is for free go do what
[ __ ] company does that you know a
[ __ ] top secret if Chevy had that
documents they would actually murder
people behind good the guy got the stuff
murder yeah I mean it's uh he just
landed a rocket yeah back from orbit
onto a barge unbelievable unbelievable
right right I mean I'm sure he's
probably like killing four year old in a
basement somewhere to like balance how
and cut a satanic side yeah he's like I
needed to power my Dark Lord yeah but
that guy seems to be crushing it I bet
his phone works everywhere he's got some
kind of chip in there I know her name
yeah oh [ __ ] let's get out of here man
Oh before I go I've been talking a
little bit about this but everybody
watch this show on Netflix CNN put out I
heard about it about a year ago and I'm
finally seeing it the 70s now they've
got the 80s yeah but it's just fantastic
and I really really love it's like eight
episodes one is TV and in and I just
worship Norman Lear and all the shows
that he made at so once TV once music
wants a cult and serial killers which is
mind-boggling the other one is Watergate
which I was so fascinated by last night
because I grew up in Watergate when your
kid right eight on a BMX bike I don't
know what the [ __ ] Watergate is you know
I smell my fingers but man is this show
great and it's on on netflix oh thanks
guys for tuning in lead the reviews
thanks bye sir good to see you here
today and thanks for everybody tuning in
to the new episodes this week of my guns
and roses review and drea de Matteo was
on what an amazing woman she is so thank
you guys for tuning in keep the candles
lit see ya